in one of the most audacious smuggling
trips ever made across the English
Channel migrants came to the French port
of Bologna to steal not a small dinghy
but this 15 ton twin-engine fishing boat
we tracked down Pascal de bourree the
owner of lapel VA he's just had the
damaged boat returned to him it was
stolen two weeks ago and used to ferry
17 Iranians including three children to
Dover Pascal admits he may have
inadvertently given the migrants a
helping hand because it was normal
practice to leave the boats key in the
engine but he told me to skip her such a
complicated vessel is impossible without
some nautical knowledge actually suffice
healing breaking into a boat is easy
sailing it is not on the night of the
theft there was a low tide therefore
there are particular channels you have
to follow and you need at least a prior
knowledge of the sea so not only did
there have to be someone amongst them
that knew about fishing in this stretch
of the sea since I hear there's a lot of
money involved in such operations there
must have been a smuggler involved 20
miles along the coast in Calais we saw
African migrants trying to jump on
lorries they had forced to slow down
with their crude roadblocks but others
have the money to pay smugglers
particularly Iranians many of whom are
well-educated and are prepared to spend
thousands to go to England by boat was a
man infringement and pay 103 thousands
of 5000 euro and he give me a boat for
going to the UK and this way is not
difficult yes it's dangerous but not
difficult track is very difficult and a
strike it's very difficult
we met Iranian Ahmed and his
five-year-old daughter Miriam returning
to their tent with hot food handouts
[Applause]
Amit showed is a number he called for a
purported boat smuggler I can what for
you after money go but the smuggler took
his money then disappeared
Ahmed still wants to take his wife and
children to England by boat before the
cold and hunger of winter really sets in
it's a journey which may now be more
accessible but with greater risks than
ever before Lisa Holland Sky News Calais